over the last year several states have
passed controversial laws restricting
abortion laws passed in Alabama and
Georgia that would effectively ban the
procedure are aimed at giving the
nation's High Court an opportunity to
reverse its controversial 1973 ruling in
Roe vs. Wade the history of
criminalization prorogue provides a
window into how abortion bans will play
out if we instituted and points to ways
of reducing the number of abortions in
the u.s. while protecting choice and
reproductive health before the passage
of Roe vs. Wade
government prohibition wasn't very
effective after the first state laws
criminalizing abortion were passed in
the late 19th century women found ways
to obtain the procedure anyway even with
the threat of arrest and prosecution
hanging over their heads
upper-class white women were more likely
to find relatively safe ways to break
the law while everyone else turned to
shady operators risking infertility and
death there is no need to speculate
about what would happen if full-scale
abortion bans were restored all we have
to do is look to the past abortion was
not always a hot-button political issue
in American life before the 1850s local
papers from Kansas to New York had ads
for female pills promising relief for
ladies female physicians like madam Russ
tell solicited clients looking to be
treated for obstruction of the monthly
period but the use of coded language
merely reflected the Victorian era
sensibilities up until the 19th century
abortion of early pregnancy was legal in
common these abortion ads stirred little
controversy bearing children was risky
women were about 40 times more likely to
die giving birth than today the infant
mortality rate in the late 1800s was
over 17 percent aboard of tonics and
potions were generally ineffective and
potentially dangerous but determined
women could turn to midwives or
physicians for procedures that roughly
mirrored modern techniques when abortion
was a crime by University of Illinois
historian Leslie Reagan documents how
terminating pregnancies was both common
practice and
an open secret an estimated one in five
women had an abortion during this period
and they tended to be married an
upper-class prevalent cultural attitudes
of the time only viewed abortion after
the first trimester as immoral before
the 1850s the turning point from legal
to illegal was known as the quickening
or when a woman could feel the fetus
move which generally happens in the
second trimester quickening was an
important distinction under common law
and Catholic doctrine public sentiment
shifted in the second half of the 19th
century the criminalization of abortion
began mainly as a business tactic to
bring women's reproductive health under
control of the emerging physician class
accredited male doctors campaign to pass
abortion bans at the state and federal
level as a way to shut down unlicensed
and mostly female practitioners the end
goal to establish state control over the
medical profession
it was the newly formed American Medical
Association under the direction of dr.
Horacio store that led the effort and
criminalizing abortion store made a
passionate moral argument against the
procedure which had the effect of
delegitimizing expert female
practitioners again media coverage
skewed the reality of abortion
procedures the death rate from abortions
performed by midwives and physicians
were nearly identical yet news reports
blamed a non-accredited female
practitioners with sensationalized
stories of women bleeding to death from
botched procedures store also
capitalized on fears of falling birth
rates among white native-born women
arguing that if they were allowed to
abort it would hasten the takeover of
the country by foreigners and people of
color in 1894 then New York City Police
Commissioner Teddy Roosevelt called
white women who sought abortions raced
criminals the American Medical
Association's efforts were a resounding
success and driving the practice
underground by 1880 most states had
passed laws that prohibited abortion
except when a woman's life was in danger
and generally male doctors got to make
the decision when it came to a woman's
personal health the American Medical
Association also scored a victory at the
federal level with the passage of the
1873 Comstock law an anti obscenity bill
prohibited sending abortion and birth
control information through the US
Postal Service
while abortions were illegal most women
were still able to obtain one from
sympathetic physicians in midwives who
tended to disregard the law and comply
with their patient's request over more
than a century of criminalization from
after the Civil War to the passage of
Roe versus Wade scholars estimate that
1/4 of all pregnancies ended in abortion
another consequence of abortion bans was
law enforcement interfering and private
lives
cops fought back against illegal
abortions with arrest interrogations and
prosecution police officers and
prosecutors threatened doctors with jail
time to get them to collaborate with
local law enforcement and punishing
women who sought their services in 1902
the Journal of the American Medical
Association advised physicians to demand
bedside statements of exoneration before
treating women who had undergone botched
abortions men whose lovers had died
while having a pregnancy terminated
where sometimes arrested and charged
with failing to fulfill their paternal
obligations by the Great Depression
abortion was illegal in every state and
yet the practice had become more common
medical studies and sex surveys
indicated that women of every social
class turned to abortion in greater
numbers as the economy deteriorated but
only the wealthy and well-connected
could safely obtain the procedure
through the loophole of medical
necessity this generally involved pain
out of pocket to be examined by three
doctors including a psychiatrist who had
make a recommendation to a hospital
board women who couldn't afford this
option turned to illegal providers whose
methods brought the risk of permanent
and fertility or death
the crackdown on abortion intensified
after World War two physicians joined
hospitals in clinics and math which
brought institutional scrutiny of their
decisions stage tried to close the
loophole exploited by wealthy women by
mandating approval from a hospital
appointed committee police rated
abortion facilities and then physically
examined the arrestees while in custody
getting a safe abortion became harder so
the practice went further underground
organizations like the clergy
consultation service founded by a group
of Protestant ministers and Jewish
rabbis ferried women to states where
abortion was legal by 1970 the group was
helping an estimated 150,000 women a
year terminate their pregnancies other
groups helped women travel to Mexico or
Puerto Rico to have the procedure done
safely women who cannot access reliable
services turn to nefarious untrained
practitioners the result was a spike in
death rates from abortions in the 1960s
researchers at UCLA predicted that
criminalization would result in the
deaths of 5,000 women each year during
this time period hospitalizations from
botched abortions became a national
epidemic treating women who had
abortions complications helped convince
a segment of the medical community that
once called for restrictive bans to push
for decriminalization the professions
about-face set the stage for the Supreme
Court's 1973 decision in Roe vs. Wade
which struck down state laws
criminalizing abortion as
unconstitutional today that decision
could be overturned by the high court's
conservative majority if that happens it
will not only once again drive the
practice underground that also results
in a whole new realm of state
surveillance and misapplication of laws
to monitor women's bodies as with
prohibition of drugs alcohol and sex
work a legal ban on abortion wouldn't be
effective because so many women don't
believe the practice should be illegal
but they also have an easier time than
ever before of not getting pregnant in
the first place
one of the biggest changes since the
days when abortion first became a crime
in the 19th century is better birth
control today wider access to
contraception has driven the u.s.
abortion rate down to its lowest level
since the past
Roe vs. Wade and that number could be
brought down even further by making the
pill available over-the-counter the
major lesson of history is that
activists should focus on changing
individual minds because outline a
widely accepted practice always leads to
more human suffering
[Music]
you